foreign
ERS came to talk to you about annual
bonuses
as I understand it from The Hollywood
Reporter piece you would ask what is
your Edge
and I would love to hear you just
elaborate on the function of that
question and what you mean by that
it goes back to how you're judged
ideally you're judging yourself every
single day everyone's making their own
adjustments
every single day
and then you have external factors which
reminds you how you're doing
every single day
and there's a lot of haphazard activity
and not everything's based on logic and
reason but if you're running a business
you'd have a daily profit and loss
statement which tells you how you're
doing if you're in a restaurant tells
you what you're doing if you run a
investment fund
you know tell us what you're doing that
all those things contribute to your own
humility
and self-correctiveness right
if you're paying
somebody a bonus or a compensation at
the end of the year
you are the one that's creating that
self-awareness in that person
I've never seen anybody
come into a conversation around
compensation
and feel
as an employee that their boss
has synced up exactly with what they
think that they're worth never seen it
so within that is a Chasm of a
misunderstanding or emotion
of what you think you're worth versus
what they think you're worth
on a given year
okay and that's normal life right
ideally you'd like to have some daily
metric that just defines that like that
daily p l so at the end of the year
there's no one big event
so what I was trying to do is to try to
build in
as much of that
narrowing of that Chasm as possible
before the conversation because there's
a negotiating strategy or you could call
it like a real effort to just build
awareness saying like the best way to do
that is to ask someone to Define who
they are
and you'd be surprised when you ask them
to talk about themselves
how passive they will be and how
either
how little they will value
themselves
on the right way and how much they
Overby themselves in the wrong way and
so I said like you know people always
say what is your superpower
maybe those things are thrown around too
often these days what's your competitive
Advantage what's your Edge
and in a certain defined role
like the world of Finance or the role of
banking I said the edge really comes
into play of you know do you have a
unique idea
do you bring unique capital
or do you have a unique relationship
but I wouldn't give them the answer I
was trying to figure out if they could
get to it if someone says I work harder
than everybody else I mean okay imagine
telling like an NFL player or NBA player
I work harder
is that really an edge these days I mean
one of these things you hear like I'm
doing the best I can I'm like okay well
then you get out of bed and then what
happens
like I'm assuming everyone's doing the
best they can what everyone like says
like yeah you know life is too short
like well life is the longest thing you
know you know anything longer than life
you know it's like
this is living to the fullest as much as
you can you know yeah but then do better
than that and when you ask someone to
find their Edge or their advantage
you'll learn a lot about themselves
so was this conversation then
it was preceding the official
performance review slash decision on the
bonus this would be
a precursor sort of setting the table
Yeah months or weeks or
whatever time frame prior to the actual
conversation yes and I would rarely even
initiate it you would see people
although I had one this morning today
actually
and you know people want to get a sense
of where they stand
or how they're valued or what their
opportunity is
in the future all those are code words
for how am I going to get paid
it's fine
it is what it is
again it would be better for those
things to happen on a day-to-day basis
why am I telling you how you're going to
get paid you tell me
how are you going to get paid based on
what your answer look at Opportunity is
and my job is to provide the platform
for you to optimize that better than
anywhere else
and your job is to optimize it here and
have the free market to choose somewhere
else if you can't do that or I can't do
that and embed within all those
Solutions or scenarios is maybe some
biases or some lack of self-awareness or
my mistakes are not building the right
platform we're not managing correctly
right and so maybe as a manager of my
job is really to throw the penalty Flags
around versus manage and tell you
exactly what you're worth before I have
to Once entrepreneurial ones needing to
be secure where's that security come
from self inside or outside
you know like when you're a parent to a
child
you have to provide that security but at
some point they have to then
get unlocked right
not everyone has to be entrepreneurial
all the way but there are certain
responsibilities that I have to build
the business for people to thrive and
make sure it's that kind of environment
Mission driven and opportunistic and a
meritocracy around that and certain
responsibilities that people have within
it
to then take it competitively better
than the best they can
and then the risk I take is that they
should do it somewhere else better than
here
but I own that risk every single day
what risk do they own